Hello.
Welcome to today's stream.
Right. Let's get my screen shared.
This
one.
Cool.
So
today,
I am going to do
bad things to Linux machine running on Packet
Cloud.
As you can see, I have one
bare metal server running called Breaking Linux.
And the point of today's stream is
not for me to fail miserably and make
an arse of myself, but instead
to try and
make some common
easily made mistakes on a Linux distribution
and show how packets tooling
can help you recover from a lot of
different
mistakes, failures, etcetera.
I did solicit some feedback on Twitter
for things I could do to this machine.
Y'all are pretty harsh.
I don't plan on breaking this beyond
beyond,
you know, some network errors,
deleting some core files, things that I can
fix real quickly.
It doesn't mean that
larger problems or bigger mistakes can't be fixed
through these tools. It's just I don't want
you watching me spend an hour
pulling down dev files from a remote host
and trying to reprovision a machine online.
Right? Nobody wants to see that. Well, at
least not today because we also have KubeCon
today, and I wanna finish a technical watch
for that.
So if you do have ideas or things
you want me to try and break and
recover from, please leave a comment on Twitch
or YouTube or tweet me,
and I will take on as many of
them as I can. But first, let's get
a lay of the land.
And if someone can tell me if I'm
sounding and broadcasting okay, that would be appreciated.
Okay. So
we have
yeah. Root password is pointless.
You still need the SSH key, so it
doesn't matter if you see it.
So I need to plug in my UV
key
to connect to this machine.
And
what I want to do
is grab this IP address,
and we will just jump onto this machine
and
try and break it
in a pretty quickly repairable fashion.
So we're gonna go s h dash l
route and
the IP address.
My project does have a
we use a lot of IP addresses, so
you just
I just delete the whole known host. I'm
not fast.
To say, should we key? Push the button,
and we are in.
So there's nothing going on
on this machine. Provisioned it with a Ubuntu
20 o four,
And
I think what we'll do is
has
I don't really use a Bintu much as
well, but there's an interesting thing.
Is the network configured
where I would expect it to be?
If you look at interfaces.
Yeah. There we go. So do I have
them?
Oh, we're off the client's stuff. Okay.
So
packet when you provision a server,
it figures
the networking for you. So you get depending
on how you provision the server, of course.
So in fact, let's just back up a
little minute and take a look at this
new server page.
So
we can say Amsterdam,
c one large ARM, you pick your OS.
And then down here, you have the ability
to kind of, you know, disable
public I p I p v four address
and I p v six. So by default,
you get one of each. You can disable
them,
and that's what we have in our interfaces
file.
So we can see
this is the IP address that I actually
use to SSH into this machine.
There's my IPv six,
and then we have my local
local subnet for this facility.
So that's Amsterdam One.
So let's break it.
What I wanna do is put this in
a position
where it's probably gonna cut me off of
SSH,
and then we will try and go through
the debugging steps or the
the steps that we need to actually fix
this. We don't need to debug it. I
know what I'm breaking, hopefully.
What if
we just change the IP address?
I would suspect
that will break things,
and
we could restart networking.
So system b, restart.
Is it system b network or is it
network manager?
Just do that.
And
it is broken. Perfect.
I never thought I'd be so happy to
break a machine.
So let's copy this IP address
and
eventually, that will kick me off. We'll jump
into a new temporary directory
and
we are out.
I would not expect this to work,
yeah, because that's not the IP address that
packet gave me.
So right now, we are completely locked out
of this machine.
Wonderful.
Okay. What can we do?
So
we have
a packet provided,
the serial console over SSH,
which means that I can click on this
out of band console, copy this link,
pop over here,
and hit go.
Push the b key. I just have a
a weird SSH failure to try to inject
some term info. So I just need to
escape that.
We are in. So this is
the
okay. I always panic.
Yeah. Definitely
panicking.
Because I just missed the root password. So
I actually probably have two things that I
need to fix now.
Because I
do not believe I can log in to
this machine. Oh, no. It's back.
So
that's good that if you dismiss it, you
can get it back.
Anyway
so
next to networking,
we can
log in to this machine.
Networking.
Network. And modify
our interfaces file again.
We can put back to seven,
and we will restart
working.
And,
hopefully,
we're back.
Good.
So
that was, like, what?
Ten minutes I've been in? So
the serial over SSH is a a really
a really great way to get back into
your machine.
Okay.
What's next?
Well, what if
What if I didn't
know that root password?
Let's tackle that. So
if I refresh the screen,
the password's gonna come back. Right? Okay. So
for twenty four hours,
Packet is very kindly going to show me
that this root password is available should I
need it.
However,
what am I feeling
pretty silly?
So
I can't just type anything
because I need to type it twice.
So let's just copy
that IPv6 address I can get back. Right?
Yeah.
Let's go random
string.
I'm putting far too much effort into this,
but
get
you
and then
paste, paste,
copy.
So it's gone.
I
now do not know the password even if
I really genuinely needed it.
Let's
remodify
our interfaces fail.
And we're gonna break that again
and restart networking
Got my history.
Alright.
So I'm still logged in there in here.
So
let's log out.
And I'm now
100% locked out of the system.
And I do not know the root password,
so the the CDL over SSH
isn't gonna do anything for me.
That's a pickle.
So what what options do we have there?
Well,
what do we have available to us? Well,
I still have my YubiKey.
So I still have a way
to authenticate
with
c l over SSH. I just
I just don't have the root password.
Okay.
What we're gonna do is we're gonna keep
our serial over SSH connection alive,
and that should actually allow us
to
track the reboot that I'm about to initiate,
which means I I'm hoping and
yeah.
Let's forward. I have okay.
And we're gonna see this machine over the
serial console.
Yep. There we go. It's now rebooting,
and we're gonna see the
Bitloader too. We're gonna see Grub.
And that's really powerful because if I have
access to Grub, I can modify
the boot.
And we can do something
to
modify how the system boots to get us
in a position where
we can just put it into a shell,
mount the desk, and change the root password.
He says, hopefully.
I'm sure you can all hear the confidence
in my voice. Now this is something I've
done a million times with a physical machine.
You know, you run letters long enough, you
break it to the point where you always
have a live CD available so that you
can at least put something on that machine,
mount a desk, and start
doing your best to fix things.
And this should, in theory, be no different.
Should.
Should have been a could have.
Okay. So I can see PixiPit now, which
means Grub is coming.
Might as well grab some tea.
There's grub. So we push the arrow, stop
the old bit.
And we've got two options right now. So
single user mode is
just
changing the run level that the machine will
be up to. I would still need
the root password. So it's not quite what
we want. So I'm gonna hit e to
edit
this.
And that's just gonna look really crappy just
because,
you know,
see a little or SSH is not gonna
be fantastic,
but definitely functional enough.
Okay. So we wanna find the kernel line.
Here we go. So we wanna modify this.
It's gonna be a little bit slow, but
we'll get there. Oh, the first thing I
wanna change is
I'm pretty sure r o can become r
w.
I don't know. Maybe not necessary. Oh, come
on.
Alright. We're going back now.
I don't have to push it too many
times.
Okay. Ah, the
leaked key sequence is not recognized. That's gonna
break the book.
Okay. Let's try
okay.
So
control e. Good.
So there's
parameter we can specify where we see n
n
dash.
Yeah. That's gonna work.
Where is that? Let's
oh, no. We've
broken it. Alright. So my delete key is
not gonna do what I want. Oh,
okay. That's what that's
Yeah. So it wasn't enter I want to
do. It's control x,
and
we're crossing everything we've got right now.
A wiser man would have tested this before
streaming it to an audience of people.
Let's just close this tab just now so
we can get a look. Okay.
So we have
a bash shell
and we
have s t a three mounted.
So we are on
the actual disk.
Let's
go take a look first at our
the basis file is definitely what we expect.
We have the five.
So, I mean, let's just text that while
we're here for the
just to rule that one out now. Otherwise,
I'll forget about it later and then be
like, what have I done?
So
now password.
So passwords on Linux.
Level one of two places.
I wouldn't expect to be here yet, so
that means password is not in the password
ID file,
which means we're gonna find it in
shadow.
There we go. Our salted password.
No. I don't recall.
If I run
this, well, it asked for the old one.
I definitely when we broke it. Right?
Good.
So let's just set it to
Does it matter?
I keep trying to think of anything I
set this to because depending on what I
do next, do do I open up this
machine to other people? I don't think I
ever do. So I'm just gonna set it
to password
one, two, three.
Full end secure and secure because people don't
try to hack a brute force anymore. That's
my duty.
So
we know a fixed interface has failed. We've
reset the password,
and I'm gonna reboot this machine once more.
Oh, yeah. There's no
my pet one is bash. So
let's just reboot this
from here. Let's just power cycle it.
We should see this reboot. We're still on
the CDL over SSH line.
One hoops.
One very minor billing.
What else can I do?
Maybe I just exit it.
Oh, kernel panic. What have I done?
Okay.
Let's see. Power off, please.
Maybe I'm just being
too impatient.
K.
That's gonna can we get some sort of
status to tell us if the machine is
off?
We got oh, yeah. Then we got the
pairing off.
Ta da. Nice.
So
afternoon.
Howdy, hackers.
So this machine
is still
powering off. So we'll to that thirty seconds,
I guess.
We'll spin it back up, and then we're
gonna do one more failure scenario.
What did we cover? We covered breaking the
interfaces, using the serial over SSH. We covered
forgetting the root password or being beyond the
twenty four hours where packet is kind enough
to tell us what the root password is.
We reset the root password by modifying the
boot system,
but all of that relied on
this, my ubt.
So let's take this out of the picture.
I guess we've all done that at one
point or another. We've generated
so let's start this back up before I
ramble at you.
Push play. Yep. That's the one.
What do we do if I don't have
access to this key anymore? Or even if
it's the,
you know, the key you generate on your
machine? What's our next steps? So
we do have an option there too.
So
what I'm gonna do is
assume I've already lost my YubiKey.
We're gonna try and SSH back into our
machine.
OS might just not be healthy yet. We'll
just leave that.
Let's
just generate a new key.
That's we've lost our old key. We need
a new key.
Let's save this here. So local TMP key.
The pass phrase,
and we
now have
two
keys. I'll just do that bigger. Maybe I
should have made that bigger earlier. I need
to remember that. Okay.
And if we come back up here, let's
just turn on some verbosity.
Okay. So our OS is still
Mhmm.
Still coming to terms with itself.
It takes networking. Right? I did. Sure. It
definitely did.
Yeah. Totally be fine.
What are my other options? Other than probably
just being patient, which
I'm not doing.
So question from Rain.
Which version of Linux is this running? This
was it'd been '2 '20.
So just as one of the fast operating
systems available on packet fast, I think, means
that it professions in under one or two
minutes. I'm sure if we
let's get that another minute, and we'll come
back to that. I can always reboot it
if necessary. But when you have
when you go to spin up an operating
system or a server web and operating system,
some of them do have the star. And
that just means yeah. There we go. Deploys
in sixty seconds. So it went to twenty
o four. It's nice and quick, and the
machine gets healthy quickly.
Alright. So is this still broken?
Okay.
What about my out of band console?
My SSH.
Yep.
Machine's still there. How's that SSH?
Oh, I generated keys earlier.
Sneaky.
There is nothing up my sleeves.
Okay.
That machine looks good now. So
I have to quit that.
Wait.
Alright. Let's just get a new tab open.
I'm not gonna waste time trying to memorize
a worker terminal.
So
go back to my account directory because I
want these keys.
What I'm gonna do is just make sure
this is definitely broken.
Now that I've removed yep. There we go.
So we no longer have serial over SSH
access
and no longer have
standard access.
We we have no way to get on
to this machine.
So
let's try
casting
this.
We're gonna come to my s z at
key settings,
and we believe that test one, as I've
already deleted it locally.
We'll add test
test two, wonderful name, and go.
Now
maybe this is gonna be a lot easier
than I thought,
but I don't think seal over SSH updates
in real time with those keys, but I
could
be wrong. Yep. Okay.
Yes. It does not work. So the c
l or SSH,
to the best of my knowledge
excuse
me. And to the best of my knowledge,
using the keys
the machine was provisioned with.
So
we do have one more tool
available, which is the Rescue
OS.
So when I click okay here,
what happens behind the scenes is
the server is rebooted
and
using Pixi,
lose a Alpine operating system
and to RAM.
And that Rescue OS
will have access to all of the keys
that I can manage through my profile.
So I believe
I don't know how long it takes,
that we should be able to get into
SQLs.
And that might just take a moment as
well.
Maybe if I just hang it for now.
Just click over here.
It still says I'll ping. So,
hopefully, it's just a a matter of waiting
a moment or two.
I will
say that I have tried to use the
rescue mode, rescue OS,
a few times,
and I have had a lot of complications.
Generally, where it's either kicked me off or
I've had to kind of tell it to
reboot until more than once.
And I'm not sure what's going on behind
the scene, if I'm being too impatient, if
I just need to wait or not. Patience
is something I'm usually quite good at, but
the fear is not so much.
So I'm gonna just refresh,
I'm gonna tell it to reboot into that
again. And it's gonna tell me it's already
there, isn't it?
Alright.
So I think I just
think I just have to be patient. There
we go. There's a pen already.
Time to dance.
I don't have your confidence ring.
Really should have
okay.
It was hangable,
but not SSHable.
Does that mean that if we put it
into a printer again?
Alright. So it says Alpine.
That's a pretty quick
refusal.
That's good. The time and out one means
SSH wasn't running. Now I think it's running.
I just need to point it to my
key,
which is here.
Who who?
And
now I just have to
rid of that, accept it again,
and then
and then we're in Alpine OS.
We can mount
how dare you?
So why is my disk busy?
Potentially, I just don't understand the protection setup,
so let's check.
SDA
root partition three.
Let's
try again.
Alright. Let's try.
64.
Tab. I see it three.
Temp.
Yeah. So it's definitely to the base, it's
busy.
Why?
What's going on?
I'm doing something
silly.
The answer is usually
yes.
Let's take a look.
Definitely.
Right? I've seen that.
Can't spell that. Okay.
Oh, wait. The STP and an SDA. Okay.
Let's try.
I have STP
three.
Why are y'all busy?
I can't
mount either of my disks.
That's problematic.
I will see that.
Do I have the partition type wrong?
Resource busy.
Resource busy. Resource busy.
How about
swap?
Alright.
Well, that's a problem.
I
know what we did.
Okay.
Let's try.
That's not already mounted. Right? Let's have a
look.
Okay.
Definitely not mounted.
So why would it be busy?
I know I know. I should cross out.
Try and rescue man.
K. Let's check the docs.
Rescue.
Okay. So we tested that.
Yeah. I've tried that.
Oh, wait. Oh.
Oh, what's what's that?
Winter Earth.
Oh, okay.
Let's
try.
See, no one ever asks for your help.
DevME127.
Oh,
well, there we go. It helps if you
use the right device.
So
now we're in slash mount.
We want to
reprovision this
with my
key, which means I just have to go
into
slash slash slash
slash
s s h,
and we're gonna see my authorized key file
here.
I had the two previous keys. Have a
Yubi key and a test one which we
deleted,
which means now I need to
what was that temp directory?
There.
I get to put my key.
My key is in the temp directory.
Let's
copy this,
And we'll see the end to it just
so that I can copy that to you
once more.
We're just going into echo.
Yep.
We're just gonna then
I
there we go. We can there. We can.
And we're gonna paste that key in.
Now I can jump out. I can view
a moment
reboot.
And then
our final task is to SSH back in
with our temporary key.
So grab this IP. I will hang it
and be very patient
as I wait for my machine to be
healthy again
and recovered from the destruction of my SSH
keys.
And still in time for me to catch
the opening talk at q QConn.
Nice.
Yay.
Yeah. If I can access it onto my
machine, I will I I I will get
back to the booking very briefly before I
quick
close all of it.
And I'll drink some tea.
Oh, nice. Give me a large cup.
Machines should read a bit faster, though.
Let's see what we have here. I should
start seeing a bit in a
bit.
Alright. Come on. Be faster.
Maybe if I
stop pinging it,
it'll fill it into thinking I've given up.
And then when I ping it again,
it was arbitrary.
What I find is, like, if you just
hit return with a little bit more force,
you know, computers cannot
you know, they they try harder, I think.
No.
It's
definitely gonna come back online. I definitely haven't
broken anything.
Right?
I don't know if that was a statement
or a question.
About being
what's that been? Two minutes? Or is that
actually about
okay. So what did I change?
Which is into rescue OS,
and all I did was modify my authorized
key fail.
Yeah. I'm confident I haven't broken it.
What we can do
is maybe watch the machine booting up. Oh,
there we go.
I need patience. I just
I need more patience.
So if we SSH
using
new key,
deleting the known host,
SSH section in.
I will do my bookie.
Cool. I'm pretty chilled through that.
So
I hope that's beneficial.
I hope you have
learned how you can really recover from some
serious failures.
None of the ones none of the failures
scenarios I covered today were particularly
too daunting.
You know, some of the suggestions were to
delete and destroy most of my disk. And
I think it was definitely a call for
me to do videos where we do some
kind of more
more intricate recovery processes that aren't as superficial
as SSH keys and root passwords. Those are
really easy to fix because, you know, we
have the tools available to do that.
And and the off chance that you do
do something like,
know, say you've got some I don't know
why you were using
DD
on a machine like this, but,
you know, it is possible to
to accidentally
destroy partitions.
And we will go through some of those
filler scenarios where either it's a case of
using the tools that we have, the seal
over SSH or the rescue operating system in
order to just get data off to migrate
it to another machine that isn't is completely
so far or just
been able to reprovision sometimes.
You know, Linux
is is quite nice at helping you with
some of this stuff, and that if we
come to our app cache
our cache
okay.
Maybe not then.
So the I guess the base images won't
come with an app cache. But if you
have been updating your packages over time, the
chances are those devs are still available on
the system, which will speed up the process.
We can reprovision that that way. And, of
course, there ways we can pull those files
from other machines on the project. So we've
all looked at those kind of failure scenarios.
We will get a bit more adventurous. But
today was a nice brief
kind of introduction into what's available as things
go wrong. So thank you very much for
watching.
Have a great day. And if you're at
KubeCon,
feel free to drop me a message on
Twitter, and we can chat about what we've
seen. Alright. Cheers.